عقيد حاتم كريم الفلاحي الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي اهلا بك معنا السيد الفلاحي
اذا يوم ثقيل في هذه الحرب بالنسبه
لاسرائيل ما قراءتك لهذا
التطور نعم لا شك بانه ستكون هناك ايام
ثقيله على الجيش الصهيوني اذا ما استمرت
هذه العمليه العسكريه لان التحذيرات التي
صدرت من كثير من القاده العسكريين
السابقين تقول بان استمرار العمليه
العسكريه بانه ستكون هناك زياده في فاتوره
الخسائر بالنسبه للجيش الصهيوني خصوصا
وانه يتقدم في منطقه نستطيع ان نقول ان
فيها موضع دفاعي هو على الارض وهناك موضع
اخر من خلال شبكه الانفاق المتواجده في
المنطقه اذا ما اردت ان اقرا قراءه عسكريه
للعمليه العسكريه بشكل عام فاعتقد باني
يجب ان ابدا بالموضع الدفاعي الذي وضعته
فصائل المقاومه في هذه المنطقه ف من
الطبيعي عندما توضع السياقات العسكريه في
وضع الخطط الدفاع دفاعيه تكون المواضع
الاماميه هناك قطعات ساتره هذه القطعات
الساتره واجبها هو تاخير العدو المتقدم
الى الموضع الدفاعي ثم تنسحب الى داخل
الموضع ولكن عندما نتكلم في حروب غير
نظاميه نقول بانه دائما المناطق الاماميه
تكون هناك مفارز تعويق في هذه المنطقه
تنسحب هذه مفارز التعويق الى الداخل في
سبيل انها تقوم بتاخير العدوى اكثر وقت
ممكن ولكن دائما تكون القطاعات المهاجمه
قد اخذت الخطط بالاندفاع
هو الهدف الاستراتيجي الاكبر الذي هو
الوصول الى قلب منطقه خان يونس وبالتالي
تعتبر هذه المناطق اهداف جنبيه يتم فرز
قطعات لهذه المنطقه على ان تتقدم المحاور
الرئيسيه باتجاه الهدف الرئيسي فاذا ما
جئنا الى القراءه العسكريه للمحور الشرقي
نجد بان هناك منطقه خزاعه منطقه عبسان
ومنطقه عبسان الجديده ثم بعد ذلك بني
سهيله هذه المناطق لم تحصل فيها معارك
كبيره جدا مع فصائل المقاومه وانما تم
تطويق هذه المناطق وعزل تقريبا هذه
المناطق عن محاور التقدم الرئيسيه هناك
محور اخر ايضا هو محور الفخاري باتجاه
منطقه قيزان النجار او منطقه الجامعه
التكنولوجيه الى الجنوب الشرقي من منطقه
خانيونس هذا هو محور اخر ايضا بالنسبه
للقطعات الصهيون المتقدمه يضاف الى ذلك
بان هناك محور من الشمال ياتي من منطقه
القراره
باتجاه شارع صلاح الدين الذي تنقسم
المحاور فيه الى ثلاثه محاور رئيسيه
المحور الاول هو باتجاه شارع جمال عبد
الناصر وصولا الى سجن اصداء وقد تقدم فيه
منذ فتره على ان تكون هناك مجمع حمد يكون
الى يمين القطعات المتقدمه ثم هناك طريق
اخر او محور اخر اللي هو محور السكه وصولا
الى بلديه خان يونس والى المنتزه وهناك
طريق اخر ايضا محور اخر باتجاه بني سهيله
اذا نحن نتكلم عن محاور متعدده في هذه
المناطق استخدمها الجيش الصهيوني للهجوم
على منطقه خان يونس ئما هناك مناوره تسمى
المناوره بالخرق نعم عفوا بالعوده الى ما
حدث في هذا الحادث بالضبط سبب ما ادى الى
مقتل هؤلاء الضباط والجنود هو تفخيخ
مبنيين بعدد كبير من المتفجرات كيف نفهم
اصلا اللجوء الى تفخيخ مبنيين في حين تدمر
اسرائيل بالطيران الحربي بسهوله فيما يبدو
حسب الصور المباني لماذا اللجوء الى هذا
الاسلوب ما
الفرق
نعم الفرق بانه تكون هناك حسابات لدى
فصائل المقاومه وتوقعات بانه اذا ما جاء
جيش الصهيوني لهذه المنطقه يمكن ان يحتل
هذه المناطق التي يمكن ان تكون مشرفه على
مناطق اخرى او مناطق مرتفعه تؤمن له الرصد
وتؤمن له المراقبه في هذه المنطقه
وبالتالي التخريبات تنقسم الى قسمين هناك
تخريبات تمهيديه وهناك تخريبات مؤجله
التخريب التمهيدي هو الذي لا يرتبط
بالعمليه او بالخطه الدفاعيه بالنسبه
للمدافع اما التخريب
المؤجله هي التي ترتبط بالخطه الدفاعيه
وهذا ما يمكن ان نتكلم عنه بالنسبه لكتائب
القسام الان عندما تم تفخيخ هذه البنايات
يخصص حرس لهذا التخريب وتخصص جماعه هندسيه
وتخصص جماعه الفلق الشخص المحول بفرق هذا
التخريب عندما جاءت القوات الصهيونيه
وتمركزت في هذه البنايات صدرت الاوامر
بتفجير هذه البنايات وتم تفجيرها على
القطعات المتقدمه الامر الذي ادى الى حصول
خسائر كبيره جدا هذا يعني يعني بانه هناك
تكتيك يستخدم كحرب نظاميه بمزيج من حرب
العصابات بتفخيخ هذه المناطق التي يمكن ان
يستخدمها الجيش الصهيوني الامر الذي سيجعل
القطعات المتقدمه لا تستطيع الدخول في اي
مبنى من هذه المباني لذلك نقول بان حرب
حرب القتال في المناطق المبنيه يختلف بشكل
كبير جدا عن الحرب النظاميه او الحرب
المفتوحه لانه يمكن ان تكون البنايه
باتجاهين اتجاه يسيطر عليه القطعات
المتقدمه و والقطع والجهه الاخرى يسيطر
عليها القطعات المدافعه لذلك القطعات
المتقدمه يبدو بانها تحت رصد القطاعات
المدافعه بشكل كبير جدا وهي تراقب
القطاعات عندما وصلت الى هذا المبنى والى
ان تم الدخول به بشكل كامل ثم بعد ذلك تم
تفجير هذا المبنى بهذه الخسائر الكبيره
التي وقعت في جيش الاحتلال في هذا اليوم
هل تتوقع ان يحمل هذا الحدث تحولا في هذه
الحرب
نعم لا شك بانه عندما تكون خسائر كبيره
يجب ان تتوقف الامور ويجب ان تكون هناك
اعاده حسابات على مستوى الخطه التعبويه
التي تجري وقد تكون هذه الخسائر هي سبب في
وقف العمليه العسكريه خصوصا وان الجيش
الصهيوني لا يتحمل الكثير من الخسائر كما
قلنا وانه يعتمد في استراتيجيه بناء جيشه
على الحرب الخاطفه التي تكون لايام متعدده
لانه لا يتحمل الخسائر العسكريه ولا يت
خمل الخسائر البشريه والخسائر الاقتصاديه
ولكن يبدو بان هذه المعركه هي نستطيع ان
نقول على خلاف ما جرت عليه العاده في
الحروب السابقه مع الجيش الصهيوني ولكن هل
هذه الخسائر ستؤدي الى وقف هذه المعركه
انا اعتقد بانها ستكون سبب في اعاده
الكثير من التفاصيل بالنسبه للخطه
التعبويه واعاده الحسابات اما اذا ما
استمرت العمليه العسكريه فاعتقد بان
الفاتوره سترتفع اكثر من هذه بكثير